welcome to another episode of play watch
listen everybody I'm Alana PS you guys
just want to introduce yourselves
however you would like
well it's it's a Lana than Aust and then
me then Mike right I think I think we're
all just trying to be sort of chivalrous
and looking to the other going please
after you
alright well I'm I am Austin and I am
just over a massive dice con plague and
heading to pax where I'm gonna get it
all over again so and I'm also a
composer incidentally my name is Mike I
am relatively healthy as far as I know
right now and I'm a game director I'm
Troy and you sound apologetic Troy no I
think I'm gonna lead us stranded like
this huge hot-button topic of sound
topic
yeah of corona with lime so I was
supposed to be in Kuwait right now and
I'll end at Heathrow Airport and get a
text from my manager saying dude get on
the plane and apparently there was nine
confirmed cases of corona in Kuwait and
the Kuwaiti government shut the event
down and if I had gotten on that plane
and landed in Kuwait it would have been
a two-week quarantine whoops so they
obviously did not know we were planning
on recording this podcast bastards this
one was tricky fishes yeah we barely
came in so it's just weird because I
tell everyone it's 5:00 in the morning
right now just in case we're all
incoherent for Mike is the only one
who's like in his top of the morning
everyone the first time you guys have
seen me in sunlight I like this new look
Mike you're normally stuck in a cutting
time
it's it is basically the world is
spherical and you come now I'm sorry I'm
sorry Mike the daredevil about this but
the corona virus is affecting the games
industry in some interesting ways of
course people are dying that is much
worse than what is happening to the
games industry I wonder what getting all
upset off the bat but I mean I'm
suspecting that we will probably have or
potentially have PlayStation 5 delays
because so much the hardware is made in
China video games that they don't like
to use the white outsourcing but I feel
like that's the best way to describe it
that I get certain assets made in China
which is most Triple A games just nobody
ever talks about that have already had
delays because of the coronavirus
because the Chinese government shut down
but they basically forced holidays on
people they didn't let them go back to
work after that I think it was a
particular holiday they have so yeah
it's gonna have a pretty significant
impact on the games industry but also
naturally on conventions and yeah we're
kind of wondering what's gonna happen at
GDC which is well in packs PAX East is
this coming week and I've already had
multiple like I was going to do a
signing event with that game company
because they're they're promoting their
new games sky but I was going to be
there and they said hey come hang out
and then 20 minutes after they messaged
me they said oh actually no one from
that game company is going anymore we've
pulled out completely and like that
story has been recurring over and over
and over it's gonna be interesting I
think you just pulled out GDC like in
the last few moments as well so it's
everyone's pulling our GDC as well which
is crazy well my understanding of why
people are pulling out is because it's a
legal issue yeah it's because like with
Playstation and Facebook it's almost
weird because they have headquarters in
the Bay Area but they're pulling out of
GDC which is naturally in the Bay Area
but I'm I'm assuming that this is
happening because if one of their
employees get sick and it was at a work
function where they knew there was a
high risk they probably get sued that's
my assumption was also I'm sure optics
as well right so like
the same reason why like world or
globally PlayStation or Sony employees
are not allowed to go to GDC because if
the brass isn't going I'm not
disparaging them by the way this is just
speculation on my side but if the brass
isn't going and some lower level
employee goes that is a bad look on them
so sure it's a legality issue but it's
also like hey guys all of us across the
border agreeing we're not going but that
I think it's them the the biggest impact
as far as the industry is that has a
huge impact if hardware is delayed
because not only just think about the
launch titles that are coming to that
which are probably rejoicing because if
they get to slip and they get to polish
a little bit more they're like cool but
there are other games that are I mean
look over the last of us is coming out
Last of Us is coming out like it did ps3
was the end of a console generation and
that could potentially hurt sales even
though it's one of the most anticipated
games people could go I'll wait a little
bit longer and get it on what I'm sure
they'll end up doing for a PS 5 I have
no idea but that's the same thing they
did for for ps4 so that that has a
tremendous impact on on sales and I
think that like you said it's it's a
it's a travesty what's happening as far
as on a health level for people dying
and people getting sick but it's amazing
to think the impact that this has on
just our economy and how we function
because I mean everyone's so willing to
ignore China and pretend that they
aren't running everything in the
entertainment industry until something
like this happens because oh boy they
are I mean yeah parts of uncharted 4
were made in China significant parts
like I mean horizon zero dawn is a huge
one they had a lot of their environments
are made in China it's it's just like a
commonplace thing for Triple A at this
point and it's kind of a question I'd
like to ask you Mike does is do you
think that that happens so often because
video games are too expensive to like
the two camps see it too expensive to
make or is it just Triple A publishers
trying to save money is it that they
cause yes make them in the West
I don't buy that or is it just that
they're trying to make safe money I
think I'm a game designer so you're
describing one metric there so it's like
it's yes it's both of those things it's
it's kind of simultaneously it's worth
also saying the other the other side of
this is the China funds a lot of video
games as well yeah a lot of meetings
that take place at GDC decide what the
next games coming out for next four
years are and a lot of meetings that
aren't gonna happen because of this
publishers that are in large part owned
by $0.10 but that's not necessarily
public because the majority shareholders
rather than actually owning the company
exactly yes oh it's a make it's an
incredible part of the industry so it's
yeah both ends of the spectrum both the
workers and the owners are often kind of
from China so in terms of yeah in terms
of I'm outsourcing it's a lot of things
yes it's cost for sure it's cost I think
also it's just about where these hubs
are it's really interesting often what
will happen is with with these kind of
with what kind of tech and specifically
tech entertainment is an emerging
industry will happen somewhere and they
will lack senior leadership because
they're just starting out so when when
and when you know when trying to start a
games industry they don't have Neil
druckmann
yet because he's still a junior
somewhere learning his trade working his
way up the ranks the kind of they don't
have the senior leadership creatively
because they haven't got the experience
here so often the kinds of companies
that can exist in get the kind of games
companies that can exist in China are
either companies that are serving a new
medium so like mobile games for example
massive in China from a development
point of view because there isn't an old
guard cause it's still in its infancy or
they are doing these kind of outsourcing
services so it's not so much the whole
game couldn't be made in China but it's
the the great kind of senior level
directors and creative leads and all
this stuff they don't exist what's
interesting is if you look at India
which is a about a decade or two ahead
in terms of its star it's really
interesting looking at what
what's happening with their local games
industry and specifically their
animation industry that we're actually
starting to see productions happening in
full over their four years your favorite
3d animated movies well maybe not your
favorites maybe not not the Pixar's but
that second rung down the ladder were
being kind of a lot of the grunt work
was being put into India a lot of that
kind of outsourcing was happening to
India what happened is all of the people
who worked on those films for a decade
started to get good start to have their
own ideas of what they'd like to do
start to get the ambition to make their
own films and now we're seeing the first
generation of Indian animated movies
that's 3d animation so it's really cool
no it's really cool there's all these
new voices you see it with games as well
there's some interesting kind of across
Asia kind of game studio starting with a
China is on that path and arguably in
some genres and some platforms they're
already kind of doing great stuff so I
think that's ultimately what's happened
is you've got a lot of very young talent
but you don't necessarily have the
infrastructure above them to kind of do
a full game so they're outsourcing so I
can go sewers Asian company do that the
two biggest outsourcing studios in
childbirth of them are run by foreigners
not Chinese people both of them exactly
what I'm talking about parts of the
games industry to start those companies
upwards
yeah you're right it's that the the
Chinese actual industry still hasn't
quite formed itself and figured out its
own identity maybe but there's a lot of
young people of those companies who are
starting to think wait a minute we could
just make the games sure and those
people are going to be the people who
kind of step up in the same way as like
every director you've heard of had to
start somewhere and kind of work their
way up the ranks and and spin you got
that special dose of arrogance you need
to run a game studio to go I'm gonna
actually try and do this and that's
gonna come in that space so I think it's
just a it's a it's like a lot of things
it's we're locked into a specific point
in time and I think actually that's
gonna level out over time yeah you know
it's there's there's another perspective
in there also of from from the prospect
from like from my view on the on the
music side I have I've observed quite a
lot of
up there was some there's some there's
some hammering going on I don't know if
you yeah I just I love how like they
were patiently waiting while you guys
were talking in my mouth they start
there is a lot of perception of value
particularly of Hollywood talent from
Chinese like from the filmmaking side
and from the game development side
because I see it happen all the time
that a game that's not even necessarily
going to be made for Western markets
it's being made you know in China
primarily for a Chinese market they will
shell out enormous sums of money to hire
you know a Hans Zimmer type because they
they see it as kind of like vindicating
their production as in and that and and
there's this perception that no Chinese
composer could possibly be you know of
that level of value and it's always been
strange to me that it's like dismissive
of their own presumably enormous talent
pool because it's like that Hollywood
shine that Hollywood Sparkle will add
kind of a secret sauce to their to their
project us skate games in history does
that though like like what if we got
people from Hollywood on stage and that
like that culture has always frustrated
me a little bit because I'm like the
games industry is very cool and for very
talented people why do we keep obsessing
over Hollywood stop it especially when
there's a lot of Hollywood talent who
overtly I won't name names but I was in
a room once with a composer who is
primarily associated with film scores
and has done quite a few rather huge
movies and he has dipped his toes in the
game side of things and on a couple of
noteworthy titles but it's really only
two or three games and someone asked him
and he hasn't done one in in many years
and I was in a little kind of intimate
gathering and someone said like would
you ever want to do another game and he
was like games are never gonna reach the
level of storytelling of films and so
you know I he's like I kind of played in
that playground and but I'm just I'm I'm
over it and I'm and it's like and I
routinely see blogs hailing him as one
of the great
game composers of all time because of
two or three titles that he worked on
and members thank you I just try think
of a composer who fits your criteria to
stay interesting guest I know it's one
of those you know it's part of it is
that like if you're not a gamer I can
see how it just all looks very quaint
and and like and maybe that's a that's a
segue at some point into this into Sonic
because the minute you said that what
game I was like that's my sonic segue I
think I think because yeah I think I
think if you haven't experienced these
things firsthand and like felt the
feedback as a player it really just
looks like a kid playing with a toy from
from the outside and that's less and
less true every year games like The Last
of Us obviously go a long way towards
pushing away from that but at the end of
the day it's like the highest level
achievement visually would be like a
really good you know Pixar film and for
a lot of people they still are just
gonna look at it through that lens and
be like okay so like at its zenith it's
still kind of a kids movie or something
like you know it's still the way
animators feel like animators you know
decades a century into their art form
existing are still treated as if they
make children's stuff so there's no hope
I hope not but I guess I guess yeah our
own biases coronavirus this is gonna be
the most uplifting
speaking of gamers I so beautifully do
that was really well done I see two of
you to go see Sonic why did you do that
yes a lot of interesting conversations
about something I don't feel like we
need to dedicate a lot of time to
reviewing it but I did Mike you saw it
first you should go ahead I I are you I
can always tell when I'm not enjoying a
film because I become really interested
in the production process
what a way to lead off that's all right
I love that that's a very empathetic
approach you're like I wonder how they
made that shot and it's like you're
looking for the thing well it wasn't
even so much enjoy is just more just
trying to find answers film
it's an odd film I the things I enjoyed
I saw positives like it was it's cool to
see Jim Carrey back doing his nineties
thing it's really weird being in an
especially being in an American theatre
if you're a braise we're just generally
because you guys talk at the screen it's
so weird and they last a really strange
and absolutely things that aren't even
slightly funny I like I don't think they
find it funny it's like apology they
like want to have this crowd experience
it's so weird Mike thank you like I'll
sit that is super weird any theater
watching a film with Americans and
they're laughing at [ __ ] that's like not
even remotely funny and sometimes I'll
just be like is it possible that you're
both dead inside yes yes Austin are you
like are you like on the other side of
this I well it's funny because I do love
I do I am one of those people that kind
of pounds the drum in favor of the
theatrical experience for the crowd
experience of it I do llama DS are
funnier in a group in the same way that
you know if you go see a stand-up act
that being in the crowd you know after
the fact is never as good as when you're
in the in that room and to me that
that's an essential part of experience
horror films are probably the
quintessential example where like to
feel 200 people or whatever around you
collectively gasp or hold their breath
and anxiety like you just don't get that
at all that's good no that's good and we
have that in the UK the gasping the
becoming tense it's when people
literally start describing to the
character like it's I didn't get get out
until I saw an American movie I realize
oh people here just yelled get out at
characters on screen and they have their
interaction and it's just not something
I'm used to at all
British people are like about I assume
it's the same in Australia right people
people go in and you'll hear like
laughter and applause and Jed rarely
applause but like laughter or excitement
or whatever that's great but here yeah
it was it's weird watching sonic and
then sonic will do a joke and then
you'll hear five different people
through the theater like repeat the joke
it was just by the way that we're
talking about the act of going to the
cinema
Austin's review insightful the who but
what you're talking about Mike is that
not the definition of ludonarrative
dissonance that that filmmakers actually
go for but game makers fight against
because that whole notion of get out
don't go in there don't open the door
especially like in a horror film is
exactly what that feeling of tension and
and empathy that is is is in contrast to
what those the character on screen is
doing is exactly what we fight against
as game designers to add atmosphere
where it's game yeah kind a car is that
narrative ludonarrative dissonance
though to me isn't ludonarrative
dissonance a direct contradiction
whereas this is more just first versus
second person emotion right so like when
you're watching a horror movie you're
feeling scared for the character on
screen rather than when you're playing a
game you're feeling scared for yourself
that's ludonarrative dissonance would be
if you were watching a horror movie and
you found it hilariously funny that
would be like where it was where it's
just completely broken I think I think I
do but it's I guess it's from an
immersion point of view it's interesting
as a difference I would amount I was
watching a thing an interview with Edgar
Wright the other day and he was talking
about how tension works in movies and I
just had this moment of like I don't
think a games ever made me tense in come
on Sagan like the Last of Us is play
lost of us I heard
bad things about anxious yes but I think
I guess what I mean more more than
tension in kind of a horror way is more
kind of dramatic tension so there's the
Hitchcock thing of like the show the
bomb under the table ten minutes before
it goes off and you get the audience
kind of rolling excited like tense and
interested about what's gonna happen
with the bomb that kind I guess I'm
talking about that kind tension rather
like a horror anxious tension I have to
draw dramatic tension I've never really
kind of experienced in a game and that's
that's something that I just immediate
was like that's a cool thing to try for
in the game yeah that's all that's all
editorial and presentational right which
you don't typically get to do is your
Nolan reaming the camera which is one of
the most creatively interesting
conversations I have ever had was on
John wick with chadster he'll ski where
we were talking about the action game
and he was asking specifically about
like can you get in there with the
camera and frame it and it's like no
because no video game but that's a
really interesting kind of conversation
to have you know like David cage games
might actually do that I think calling
it a David cage game first of all is a
bit of a stretch shots fired
no Detroit was honestly a game that I I
thoroughly enjoyed that and I enjoy as
well actually yeah but I just real
quickly might to your point it's not
just about camera framing but it's also
using like the rope or using that
Hitchcockian thing where it's like show
the bomb the scene plays out
continuously right so if I was gonna do
that in a game from a directorial
standpoint if I wanted to establish the
bomb that with the Android on the
balcony with the hostage right that's
what I mean by like I feel like Detroit
become human actually great job and wise
and keeping it interactive as well as
opposed to what what the temptation
would be and
one-to-one would be from film to to game
is like keeping in a cinematic now it's
not a game anymore it's just a CGI movie
because in order to and you're
absolutely right that in the very
beginning that a great performances
Brian deck arts laid it in that and it
still allowed me to have some agency
while from a brilliant standpoint
tutorial izing me on how to play the
game that was even just walking through
that that apartment and the very
beginning and like this is how he it's
very very simple how we play this game
and but teaching me the mechanics by
whilst also you know revealing to me the
world was it was a really you know smart
ploy but I think that you can't do what
what Hitchcock did because Hitchcock is
literally all one shot kind of thing
keeping it and then every once in a
while reminding you that this thing is
underneath there and we can't do that
because we have to take the player off
the stick in order to do that and that
that's the issues of an agency versus
it's what you're talking about with
watching sonic in control of the
experience and you're actually right the
lack of control you have in a movie is
what a large part of what's fueling that
tension so so ya know it's a really good
point but it's exciting to me I mean
this may be some way of doing any
different way but at some point I'll
give a go and massively fail and pretend
I never tried in the first place the
problem with Sonic
oh go on Austin well I just want to
comment on the very last because I think
I I always the game industry is so
intensely creative at that
problem-solving and and and at like
discovering new problems and then
solving them and and there's such a
rapid sort of iterative cycle I feel
like on that it's it's it really to me
always feels like how the film industry
must have felt like in the 30s and 40s
when there was just constant technical
advances everything was kind of by
definition ambitious because there just
wasn't much precedent for anything and
and so whenever I hear these comments
like games will never blank I always
roll my eyes because I'm like
it's just that would be like saying you
know it's the ultimate okay mullah
movies yeah it would be like going back
and watching you know like 1939 and
sitting there watching you know Wizard
of Oz in the theater and then saying
okay I know exactly what movies are and
what they can be and they're never gonna
be XY and Z and like with no with no
ability to anticipate the the jaws the
Close Encounters the star wars the the
aliens I know take off but then when
Mickey Mouse was in theaters first
cartoon or animated thing ever in
theaters it was statistically seen twice
by every single American yeah it's
interesting how much we're coming in so
anyone watching this in the UK Edgar
Wright there's like a BBC iPlayer
interview I comment always called like
cinema something but just yeah search on
iPlayer Fraker right because he's
touching on lot of this stuff and he
actually comes in from the other angle
Austen where he's like it really like he
I think at one point is like showing a
clip from like a 1930s thriller and he's
like this is better than most of what we
do nowadays in film that's a problem
right because he sees it from the other
side where he's like actually in a
medium where they have tried a lot of
stuff and there is arguably some
stagnation but then you see you know a
new film does something original every
year so it's an interesting one yeah for
games where in is this amazing position
where we are still we're not even at
like Charlie Chaplin yet we're so we're
in the within the within the kind of
human metaphor I see us as teenagers
where we don't we perceive ourselves to
be invincible we are smart enough to be
able to actually do things substantively
but we don't know yet the limits of our
of ourselves and we make so much money
and there's a yeah well and there was
something else that I just a random
thought when you were talking about like
the potential of ludonarrative
dissonance in a movie versus a game and
that when you were kind of both breaking
that down
sorry one thing that I'll just and I
explained it real quick for anyone who's
watching you doesn't know what it is
ludonarrative dissonance is basically
the idea that whatever is happening in a
video game is different to what the
narrative is telling you so say a story
is about having trouble thinking an
example now
story of the game is about someone go
but and doing it non-violently but then
a lot of what you do in that game is
kill people very bad example that I
throw up but that's ludonarrative
dissonance is two things that are very
at odds with one another Mario is a
plumber but he never plums true stress
jumps just jobs it's it's a terrible
video game Miyamoto when will he make a
good game finally no no IIIi just I when
when you made a comment about like the
closest film equivalent would be if a
horror film was was hilarious that to me
it doesn't actually feel like the same
thing because that's no to me it's like
definitely a weak metaphor yeah to me
it's like if a horror movie is hilarious
it's either just a badly made horror
film or it's like that brand of kind of
camp Kitsch horror that's that's you
know your grindhouse
yeah exactly
you know what it is the new narrative
dissonant film is the room that is a
film that is telling you it's about a
guy who is I mean it's a guy basically
dealing with a breakup yeah via the
medium of film while you're laughing at
it like that does that fit that was an
intentional intention it's about
something but it is actually absolutely
not about that about forks and spoons
yeah because games like a lot of the
time the ludonarrative dissonance occurs
because you have to have gameplay and so
they get distracted by the stores my
favorite is when they tell you off for
playing the game where they like you you
must kill 50 people then you kill 50
people they're like wow you're a bad
person for killing a pilot it's like
what I think by the way I think that
just to kind of tie it
with with the comment about the sort of
infancy of the industry I actually think
a lot of that is just because of the
fact that taking storytelling seriously
is in is a more recent development than
taking mechanics seriously
you know since games began almost
exclusively as non narrative you know
going all the way back to pong you know
the these were not story driven games
these were mechanics driven experiences
and and so it's like at some point it
was like let's staple a story on top of
our of our mechanics as a kind of skin
graft and and so as a result there's a
there's been this game of catch-up of
like how do we actually make a game
where the story and the mechanics are
kind of birthed into the air magically
in the same breath like you think of one
and you think of the other and they're
they're two sides of the same coin and
that's first off that's that's hard to
do especially because a lot of game
directors I think are designer a lot are
designers by nature so they'll think of
is why I was always working with that
game company on journey was always very
noticeably unusual being with tgc in
general and with Jenova Chen
specifically because he tends to think
of an emotion and then says how can I
make a game that evokes that and he
doesn't care about what mechanics that
ends up being he doesn't care about what
story that ends up being it's like I
want you to feel X like in journey I
want you to feel alone what would make
you feel alone okay well again that
starts single player that then contrast
that with multiplayer and it puts you in
an environment you know the desert was
chosen entirely based on the emotional
implications of a desert it's not like
you had a mental image of a desert and
said oh what game could take place there
that could be interesting right like it
but that's the flip of most people I
think most people are like oh I've been
[ __ ] around in unity and I or in
unreal or in whatever and like I've got
this jump mechanic that's really
satisfying and like okay what else can I
do with that and like I should come up
with a story that somehow justifies this
I mean I know some of my friends who
have game writers have this massive
problem between the design team is like
we want to put this in the game
shouldn't affect a story though you'll
be fine and then the right is like no oh
my god
right around the story these two levels
are gonna get swapped so all of your
beats are now I'm saying yeah all the
designers don't realize how much the
story changes based on one small thing
changing and worse the designer thinks
they're a writer which is always the
really scary that's very common well
made was telling me I was a writer I was
doing fine so back to sonic what do you
think I tried to figure out the
production I do want to like come back
and talk about the ADR and reshot
process because it's fascinating yeah
but I do want to hear whether Austin
Austin you loved it right best yes best
picture undoubtedly I well just one
other quick commenting off of sonic this
is so unfair
I wish you could have been there at this
we had drinks and in Vegas tearing dice
and just trying to tell 1/3 before I
tell that story was everybody read this
we all need to just pass her it was mine
it was my feet or it was his first time
meeting these two and the guy that was
trying it was like sir I'm just trying
to get your drink order and we're like
it was dead but first and like we're
mixology comes from itself and doesn't
conversation holy Sh here's my point
it's worth it's worth commenting that
just on the whole thing about like weird
American movie theater experiences
because that that to me that actually
was part I was the only one in the
theater
actually at one point was being on Hilla
and at one point I think there was
another couple and hilariously they were
as you described like the guy that
literally there's four of us and 250
empty seats this was at an arc light and
and and the dude was like the other guy
ten rows behind me was like overtly
laughing and stuff which I was kind of
baffled by so I guess I started a cinema
full of adults there was not a single
kid that was named in my place as well I
think it's a very much like I don't
think kids today would probably even
know what Sonic I imagine they're still
going to see it because it's a blue
animated thing but I was like the reason
this movies done so well commercially is
because so many adults know what Sonic
is interests carry those laps right yeah
kind of age you would be that you would
love Sonic is the age where you grew up
watching yeah a stranger a liar a liar
that kind of error yeah I mean he was my
favorite part of that movie my review is
that I thought it was it was fine I was
expecting it from the get-go with all
those production issues to be like cats
bad like I was expecting it to be
terrible and no matter what I was gonna
see Sonic was always gonna happen so I
thought it was completely fine I think
my biggest gripe is that I found Sonic
annoying but you know
fine fine film the film was fine it was
mostly the thing was it was it was more
explicitly because I think what you said
is true the Jim Carrey sort of appealed
to I guess Millennials and and and Gen
Xers like people that are like
definitely not kids today like his his
for a human yeah his cash is is on 90s
and and and like doing that shtick right
he was doing nineties Jim although
although very you know I kept reading
like oh it's awesome Jim Carrey's back
and I thought he was actually very
reeled in like and and in a few times it
was was weirdly forced like it just felt
like they said okay do your thing and it
kind of was random and had nothing to do
with the the movie it just felt like
they were sequence right which just like
the whole thing
and he just does a Jim Carrey for about
three that's exactly what I'm referring
to
yeah but the thing is that strange to me
is despite all of that being true and
therefore seemingly obviously the target
demographic being people you know you
know mid-20s at the youngest it was
pretty explicitly a kids movie like it's
like the the humor and the the general
kind of like it's a very uncomplicated
story and very kind of straightforward
like I got to do a thing help me do my
thing okay we did the thing and that it
all feels very catered in our era of
like Pixar films aspiring to kind of hit
both at once where there's a layer of
depths yeah yeah exactly
the the this one did not seem to even
have that goal it didn't it just but yet
it is strange that's everything about it
would seemingly need to target an older
crowd can I share my theory on this sure
because it ties into my ADR thing so
obviously the big story about the sonic
movie was that they redid Sonic because
the outcry right my big theory is that
they they didn't just take away we need
to get the sonic character looking right
from that I think they also suddenly
realize that the main audience for the
film they were making was older because
because basically the people who cared
about there were no eight-year-olds
complaining about how sonic looks it was
and I think then if you watch the movie
with the intent of going this is a film
where they redid the CG to make Sonic
look more like Sonic and also where they
realize they're an audience over 10
we're going to show up to the cinema it
suddenly makes so much more sense all
the structure all the story is what
you're doing Austin it's like a very
simple straightforward kids movie all of
the jokes that are targeted there are
kind of by the referencing pop culture
or a little bit kind of flirting with
something kind of adult in content are
either ADR or this character who I'm
convinced is not actually in the
original script who's sat in a room
taking phone calls you never see that
character until the very end of the
movie you don't see that character in
any context in the harp there is the
other cop the other cop only exists to
be called intermittently throughout the
movie and the side of the conversation
that's Madison with Sonic doesn't
actually say anything to him it's always
just all him ad-libbing in a room with
Jim Carrey walking into that room once
presumably the most expensive reshoot in
cinema history where Jim Carrey walks
into this like four by four meter office
that's my theories so much was added in
post not that the important rearmost
expensive rishu with a bend the one
where we got rid of Kevin Spacey an
entire movie it was a movie wasn't it so
like so and yet every joke that is
targeted at any audience of day isn't
basically a fart joke is said by a
character with their back to you by
radio so movie i rewatch it with that in
mind when it goes up on Netflix I think
the whole thing has been rebuilt to
target the audience yeah I mean to
contrast what you said Austin my
impression was that it actually skewed a
lot older than I expected it to and
that's because I think I'm comparing it
to detective Pikachu which is a movie
that like really got me like I found it
heartwarming because I was so much loot
that film yeah but it was some of the
issues with detective Pikachu is that
they tried too hard to explain the plot
where is like you don't make a plot for
kids you make the visuals for kids you
make some of them jokes for kids youyou
have physical gags for kids but you
don't need to make a plot for children
because children aren't gonna care about
the plot generally anyway so in
detective Pikachu they would have like
someone explain what has happened
and then a shot of what's happened and
then a flashback of it happening like
you'd be like kids kids kids me like
don't do that you
don't need to it's so it's such a stupid
way to tell a story have the plot for
adults have other stuff for kids and
sonic didn't do that so I couldn't stop
in my head comparing these two movies
and being like Oh Sonic was actually
more mature than I expected despite
still being yes extremely simple
and there are there were jokes in there
that I was like huh they didn't think
that they would even touch on that
there's so many references to Olive
Garden like that's a right that
placement as well yeah as a product
placement for I can't remember the name
of it it doesn't exist outside of
America or it doesn't exist in the UK
Li's there's like there's like a letting
agents like he's looking up there
looking up places to live in so yeah
Zillah
happened and I watched that and I swear
I I would put money on the fact that
that's been localized that if I went to
see when I watch that in the UK because
they do that all the time it'll be a
it'll be a UK house hunting website what
is it with nintendo always making their
movies Bladerunner ripoffs i just
occurred to me like Super Mario Brothers
is totally kitties Blade Runner yeah
neons everywhere Neil like basically
yeah like like a Super Mario Brothers is
like the original Blade Runner directors
car detective Pikachu is over explaining
everything via voiceovers that's like
the cinematic release of Blade Runner
it's good yeah it's I think I don't
comedy routine for they just did their
worst impression of Jerry Seinfeld as
well awful oh my god run by your before
this podcast was going to be how do we
feel about the production house catering
to fans where Sonic is concerned is that
something they should or should not have
done so you'd like me three people
working in the games industry to tell
you if they think the game that's what
you know like you'd like my voice I
I will with apologies I because I did I
did an interview with polygon where they
said like what was your as one of their
retrospective like the decade is ending
and they would did a story of you know
various folks in the industry reflect on
what they thought was some of the
biggest like stories or news items or
developments or something like that of
the last decade and my mind was actually
this subject where I said I was I was
very fascinated by the Mass Effect 3
story because I I liked I I see that as
a largely positive story because I see
it as an example where they got an
enormous amount of player feedback and
the thing is I played the game only
after it was impossible to kind of play
the initial release I didn't I didn't
circle around in Mass Effect 3 and tell
the the redone ending was baked in and
just endemic to the game and and I
remember thinking it was solid I
remember thinking you know is an
ambitious game very hard ending to pull
off and they did it as good a job as I
could have imagined anybody doing and
then when I went back and like watched
youtube videos of the original ending I
thought well that's substantially weaker
I I actually think that they made a good
call here and I think that you know of
course fan outrage can be incredibly
toxic and it can be very difficult to
parse and to kind of separate the wheat
from the chaff but we live in an era
where I mean like like cats is a similar
thing cats actually got patched they
actually sent theaters updated copies of
the movie with improved CG like the
following weekend and I think we live in
an era where you know that separation
between not released and released is
getting a lot more permeable and it's
hard for me to see that as a downside
because I also have the big caveat of
like I respect developers and filmmakers
to set their own boundaries and like
respect themselves enough to know when
to not do it and with that assumption
baked in which may or may not be fair
because there can be a lot of pressure
to me like Sonic they clearly
objectively improved the film and like
and they've been commercially rewarded
for doing it it's made like two hundred
to two hundred plus million dollars
and you know I don't I think I heard
that it was a 20 or 30 million dollar
bump to do that to do that crazy work
and they had to delay the movie by like
six months or whatever but it clearly
made it better it seems like it surely
made it better and so I'm like ah you
know it did look really horrific yeah I
was kind of scary the the I think the I
think you can separate the issue into
the two parts which is the reaction and
the outrage so I think I think players
absolutely have the right to dislike
stuff and to complain about it and make
their feelings known that's that's good
and healthy and supports a good film and
games industry then you've got the
choice you make as someone who has to
make stuff like whether you listen to it
and and sometimes that decision is
massively artistically motivated you're
like screw you guys I'm going for
something here this is the thing
often it's financial or you know
practically based like there's
definitely flaws in probably every game
I've made I would love to go back and
tweak but you just don't have the time
or money to do that I think also the
thing that's interesting with the sonic
stuff is that yes it paid off for the
studio but it absolutely destroyed the
VFX studio who made this effect so sonic
they went back they crunched it and they
crunched a star for six months and then
fired everyone that's you no longer
exists
now that doesn't that's not the fault of
the players who raised valid complaints
it's the fault in my opinion of this the
studio system that allows that to be the
case the company can make a movie make
200 million and the people who actually
made the movie are jobless that's a
that's a broken system but to me that's
a separate issue to the audience
reaction I mean as long as the old
interaction doesn't become toxic or
aggressive I say I want to hear those
thoughts yeah it seemed I agree I am
looking at it through a very kind of
purified lens of never mind the working
conditions that that of course that adds
a layer of complexity to the discussion
that's well worth having but just from
the highest level and the most maybe
naively idealistic level like is it good
that the that they that they release
that trailer with enough head
you know kind of run way ahead of them
that they were able to do something
about it cuz then you know cuz what's
the alternative yes they crunched but
the alternative is this movie comes out
like I just I just read an interview
with Danny Elfman
that was like a 35-year career
retrospective and he made this comment
about how you know he said it can be so
heartbreaking when you spend five months
working on something and in a weekend
it's gone like no one cares and he goes
and that's I have it easy I only worked
on it for five months think about the
writers director all the actors you know
sometimes people sink years of their
life into something that from Friday to
Sunday has ceased to matter that one's
not me I don't know what the hell that I
had clearly that they're taking out the
trash outside my patan was like sounds
like your apartment is transforming it
isn't me right now they're to do it on
Wednesdays we don't get the gardener's I
think it all matters on what product
you're trying to make if you are trying
to make art then I believe art should be
accessible
otherwise it's purely masturbatory
cuphead just released a celeste like
easy mode and that's such a hot-button
issue right now is like should these
games be accessible to everyone and I
think my thing is always as many people
should be able to play or experience as
many video games as possible and I think
that is beneficial to literally all of
us but I would also never want to
compromise on creative vision I just
feel like in most cases you can probably
figure out a way to do both you can it's
not a creative concern it's apparent it
comes back to practicality as I say it's
I can't afford to do I don't think
there's many people actually in the
games industry you'd have any problem
with making quite easy that's why it's
only done it now right like we don't
want people to have a good time and it
wasn't like an internal creative down
here it was just the practicality yeah
you're absolutely right if if Everest
was accessible to everyone it wouldn't
be Everest if Atlas Shrugged was a
novella it would
be such a thing to read it it's there
are things that I feel that should be if
it's like you said a lot of creatively
that's the vision of it is that this is
a tome this is this is difficult this is
hard it's it's not accessible to
everyone it's only accessible to those
who are willing to put forth the effort
to understand or to or to tackle it or
whatever the task is but I think that if
you know I don't I don't feel that
people were setting out to make art with
with Sonic so therefore I do believe
it's like we're going to pander to the
audience because ultimately what this is
it's fan worship it is it is a
celebration of an icon so let's make it
what you want it to be oh [ __ ] did we
[ __ ] up the character model sorry our
bad we'll fix that because we want this
to be the sonic that you know they
weren't trying to do a gritty reboot of
Sonic so I think it's totally fine when
you're dealing with with stuff like that
however when you're this is why I like
stuff we can go back to the whole you
know genesis of this with Star Wars how
else you gonna land that's true we
haven't talked about Star Wars is like
man I don't know dude how do i you know
sync up over 40 years of a franchise
that has become so expounded upon an
answer don't try don't try maybe yeah
maybe don't do that that's a very
Western culture thing to close the loop
and to put a bow on it look at Japanese
culture and it's just like that's it
that's all we're gonna tell that's
there's probably infinite volumes of
this story that we can tell but we're
just gonna tell this I remember talking
to the creator of Afro Samurai and him
saying that the the slice that you saw
of that show was was such a small
segment on a thousand-year timeline and
he had all of that written but he just
chose to do this and be fine with people
wondering and and speculating everything
that to me is art when people can take
what you've created and expound upon it
that is accessible to a level that now
it becomes bigger
than what you what you have intended it
to be but III think that no in a case
like Mass Effect you should stand by
your ending and look at the last of us
that's Neil knew that it was going to be
a very dividing and divisive thing to
say I'm this is my ending and people are
gonna wrestle it and I'm never asking
heels like are you afraid that people
aren't gonna like it he goes I don't
care if people love it or if they hate
it I just don't want them to be
ambivalent I don't want them to go
that's okay so I think that there's a
big difference though between the ending
of Mass Effect 3 and the Last of Us
because the Last of Us makes a bold
statement and it is what it is Mass
Effect 3 was like a culmination viewer I
think yeah I think Casey Hudson's
argument would be clearly what I was
trying to say didn't come through and it
needed another pass it's not it's not
that it was divisive in the sense of I
made some bold Proclamation and I
definitely did what I intended to do and
like it or not that's what it because I
agree with you absolutely people should
stand by their convictions but if you if
I'm if I'm trying to write the world's
perfect melody and I play it for you and
you're like I just don't really get
where it's going it's it's just it feels
wandering and it feel it's like at some
point I have to say I think I didn't
stick the landing I think I need another
pass your feedback is it's not that I'm
caving my artistic integrity it's just
that I didn't do as good a job as I
hoped to and I should take another swipe
I think is interesting like that we're
talking about this and we're bouncing
back and forth between story interaction
in terms of like accessibility we're
talking about features that that's what
that's the massive challenge of game
making is that we are making design
we're making stuff that is that the
users interaction with it is also the
thing we're not where reach like if you
made films but you were reinventing
cinema every time it's like it's really
hammer and scratch exactly like it's a
really it's crazy the challenge we sell
it's amazing any video games
um but it's it's it's entry but there's
an interesting kind of overlap to love
what we're talking about and I think
that ain't where those lines are drawn
is an interesting conversation because I
actually I actually agree with Troy in
the case of Last of Us that that's a
vision that's what it is but I agree
with you Austin in case of mass effect
because that was to me there was an
ending that wasn't doing what it wanted
to do and it's I just I think the nuance
is fascinating where something like
sonic they're just yeah they're just
they're just making it for the audience
they're making for but I think when a
filmmaker high art film like independent
films that filmmaker still cares about
how their thing is received right if an
indie filmmaker make something look I
mean we talked about Blade Runner
earlier right Ridley Scott has messed
with five because it's for him he's
making arts he thinks he's making art
the film community agrees he's making
art he's making are but for him he just
wants to make the perfect version of
that art across cop heads interesting
because I hated cop head because I just
was too difficult for me I couldn't get
around it if I there's an easy mode
means I get to play cop head now and
that's that's the interesting debate
about like difficulty and well you know
sec hero shouldn't have a an easy mode
every game how if you're if you're if
you're [ __ ] at video games every game is
hard and frustrating you still play them
because you enjoy them why not move that
bar back and forth and it can be [ __ ] a
video games obviously there's also
physical disability that's always folks
I've worked with the amount of the
community that are people who actually
have disabilities that that aren't
catered to I think is an area that we we
can massively whittler its testament to
how important and cool games are being
the lens folks with physical
disabilities go to in order to play it's
amazing like the setups you see I've
tried some of them it's it's the the
obtuse nature the solutions people have
had to build to play games yeah without
our help as creators shows you how eager
they are to play and we should do what
we can to kind of encourage able game I
wanna just very quickly
sorry sorry I just want to comment
parliamentarian Laurel since since Mike
votes my name
one minute because I feel like you're
gonna be able to tie this up but to
speak to something that I get about the
mass effect thing I believe that right
now we can't solve this and I do believe
that it's a problem because what mass
effect was trying to do was it can't
give me agency throughout the entire
experience at the very end remove that
for me so that they can tie up their
story the answer what's on the other
side of the equal sign for that is
procedurally generated narrative for the
game to respond to my decisions in a way
that at the end of it the culmination of
it it satisfactorily answers my story it
ends my story which will be vastly
different than your story vastly
different than Mike's story so that's
that's what that's that's that's what
we're doing right now right and and and
even Ken Levine has talked about that
that we want to go that's what yeah it
is can I take and that's the beauty of
it
ken is yeah ken is like look I'm gonna
what I'm trying to do is not make a game
I'm trying to change the way the games
are made and if he pulls it off then he
will have done that that will be Ken
Levine's legacy and I think he will
honestly be done after that because
there's nothing else like it it's Ken
said that he thinks that every first
place first play a game and I know like
a lot of audiences don't don't agree
with this but it's just ha fly free
skinned he's like every first-person
shooter is just you took the formula of
half-life and then you kind of made it
your own but it's just the same thing no
one's really changed anything
dramatically and what Ken Levine is
doing is dying like two is touching on
it a little bit as well and a lot more
publicly is finally figuring out a way
for games to take advantage of being
video games of of that technology of the
software that we have the films cannot
produce which is at all about player
agency
I think that that is our next step if we
keep talking about how well like
teenagers right now I think probably a
little further into turning 18 and
finally illegally drinking alcohol is
video games focusing more on player
agency and yeah I absolutely like very
strongly they all some Ken pulls up what
he does games a different forever the
awesome thing about games is what you're
describing right now sounds ridiculous
and stupid and impossible and in three
years there'll be a plug-in I can buy
for $10 that lets me put it in my game
like that's the beauty of this evolution
is that it's it sounds ridiculous what
you're saying it sounds every like every
like producer bone in my body in terms
of like scoping a project getting
something's its release date hitting
milestones is saying this is nonsense
and yet I know it's where it's going
eventually and once it does it's gonna
feel so calm place Dreamz is amazing man
play that very development and it's just
phenomenal I I almost dropped everything
you just went and start making dreams
stuff like when I played that by year
ago is amazing I I want to I want to
kind of wrap all that together because I
have I'm curious all of your opinions on
the sonic movie is is I think it's it's
probably it's probably the most
palatable good video game movie yet made
to be honest and the thing is though as
we would all I think acknowledge that
bar isn't abysmally low and I think it's
it's worth a lot of people have talked
about this but I just am curious I have
my own thoughts but I'll hold off at
least until you guys wrestle with it for
a second what why why do you think that
is why is it that game adaptations seem
utterly cursed to make for garbage films
I think there's a probably a bunch of
reasons but I'm curious if you guys have
thought about this my guys a Hollywood
executive misunderstanding of why people
like video games
that is what my guess has always been is
yeah you like Ezio that's it in it then
it's not
so that just like who cares you'll go
see it because we have the character you
like you like that's not why we like
Assassin's Creed you falsely
misunderstood yeah I was gonna say I
think I think you I think you nailed
part of my thought on that as well but I
think it's more specific than just they
don't understand why people like games
it's it's specific to every IP like that
was part of exactly why I was so cold to
Sonic is I was I said this that no one
cares about story in those games they
they have they are pure McCann I mean
there probably is a story and because I
mean like dr. Robotnik is a character
and whatever but like it's purely about
the tactile feedback of the of the
mechanics and so it's like how do you
even make a movie that remotely
approaches that because you just you
sacrifice that as soon as you get rid of
the player agency you lose the only
thing that makes it appealing it's the
same reason why Mario I think probably
cannot possibly work as a film because
again who cares about any vestige of a
story that there there maybe that's not
why you play it and I think that it's
it's game specific because yeah like in
the Assassin's Creed movie is an
interesting example because that's a
very story rich thing and yet somehow
that's just like they just didn't
understand the game yeah like I got a
theory I'll go with you yep I've just a
very aware live crave talked too much on
this podcast so I know we're celebrating
how clear you look that's good that's
right yeah it's I can just see the
comments Mike talks a lot I'm too big or
too small
I guess the big problem with games in
terms of adapting any story novels are
good because novels are about eight
hours and you can kind of either trim or
refocus and get a movie out of it that
that kind of works but when you look at
games games are either like you say like
two sentences on the back of the box
like Sonic or Mario or its Assassin's
Creed and it's the entirety of human
history has been a conspiracy and
there's never any in-between and I think
that that leads to really impossible
challenges in terms of adaptation of how
you take those stories and make them
work I actually I'm gonna stand up a bit
I actually really like to all craft a
genuine the whole Warcraft
good for someone who's not I'm not I
don't know I don't know I'd never played
the games I think that might be the
reason I like it cuz I think the people
who were fans the games like had issues
with it I thought it for me it felt like
a movie though it was like an alternate
universe where Willow was like as
successful as Lord of the Rings and we
went down the kind of silly a fantasy
rather than the kind of dark muddy
fantasy that it's getting friends or
whatever it felt like it was from Mirror
Universe but I really liked it um but it
ran into the problem of Warcraft has
about 40 minutes of establishing shots
right at the star because they have to
establish Warcraft as a concept people
like me who have no idea what it is so I
think that's the big problem I think
that's why generally I think game
adaptations that work arriver the ones
that something like the witch which I
didn't personally dig but I know lots of
people loved where they just took the
time and did a TV show and went back to
the short stories and kind of kept scope
logical or it's something like sonic way
you can kind of impose whatever story
you want because it's two sentences Lego
should the lego movie right that
shouldn't have worked but because there
was no story in Leo they could kind of
invent something little and go and I
think that's where we're gonna see I
think the games that are going to
translate well into movie and television
are the massive games that get adapted
into TV or the very small story games
which was a sweet story yeah that wasn't
too grounded in anything because Pokemon
has never had to be unless you know the
anime which it just was necessary they
were like no let's just do something new
with these things
I'm they used they were so and this
isn't laziness this is smart they use
the oldest trick in the book if you've
got a big world you need to establish
new film or it's the oldest you make
your protagonist someone who's
constantly asking questions boom you've
got your wall building you just do it
exactly you like these detectives or
such a useful character type to put into
a wall so I've used it that was a great
call what's this why what's the yellow
guy yes
you're amnesiac detective that's the
perfect in but that's the thing I think
you can do when you're doing a looser
adaptation and adaptation set in a world
or based on something simple is you can
as if you're a screenwriter
I assume I've never wrote a movie or
written a movie or never rode for but I
assume a film writer has all the
screenwriter just like a game developer
has all of these tricks they can pull
out and if they're allowed to use those
tricks they can probably make a good
movie and if they're not because they're
constrained by the law document from
Ubisoft of five hundred pages of this is
anymore it's gotten out of hand
but but then I loved mythic quest so I
now love I love Troy do you have a take
on on Austin's question that's the craft
of the voice actor right the craft of
the voice I suppose
[Laughter]
me yeah I don't sit here that's right oh
so now you're right yeah I have a couple
more minutes
I recall culated my heart my heart out
and and I came in and got some just
excited by how interest in these mining
becomes well why video game film
adaptation so bad
[Laughter]
mm-hmm
hmm
I mean if you need a monkey you put
circus in them okay I was gonna say Andy
Serkis
circus is your monkey like that's just
how it works
funny it's Troy you actually just made
me think of something like a slight
variation on this that I hadn't thought
of but but kind of ties to our other
comments we've made here today of
funny enough part of the reason why some
of these adaptations might not have been
working especially on the like 80s and
90s nostalgia movies like Sonic is
entirely because of the immaturity of
the source material because I kept
thinking to myself like because when you
said I don't care about the story I care
about doing the leap of faith I thought
to myself well The Last of Us is an
interesting exception where it has
thoroughly conceived characters and it
is telling a story mmm in a in a
language that's far closer to that a
film so could a Last of Us film
adaptation work and I was thinking to
myself probably a lot more successfully
than a sonic one because ironically it's
it's like a higher level of storytelling
just overall top to bottom do you think
the loss of us like I've always thought
would make a great TV series but then
you lose one of the coolest things about
the lost of us which is that it doesn't
have ludonarrative dissonance what
you're watching narrative Lee is very
intense but then the gameplay is also
very intense so you lose like one of the
most exhilarating things about
experiencing the lost of us which is
that stealth gameplay it still relies it
still relies on the gameplay yeah like
lost of us lost of us we started off
talking about tension I made a stupid
fakes a statement that was immediately
torn apart correctly as it should be but
like there was a but there was but yet
like Last of Us the tension of lost of
us is about me not being able to craft
the things I need quick enough or I need
one thing I can't find any these goddamn
drawers I'm like there's that's the
that's so much like obviously Troy's his
we have to be nice but like the story
side of it
know the story say there is awesome but
the story side of it is a part of a
whole other hand it's just gameplay so
when it comes to the story I think film
studios benefit benefited by being able
to do whatever the [ __ ] they want yeah
and it works both ways we did it like
when we decided to do John wick that was
part of that we had this conversation of
kind of do yeah but the great thing
about John wick is John wick is a bloody
video game like in terms of its in terms
of like its structure and story we
looked at the oh we we when did lots of
analysis and I've talked about this in
very boring interviews like we we
figured out like no John wick is a video
game narrative already and that's
definitely the viewpoint of the the
creators of the movies as well like they
it's part of the DNA of that so yeah we
can pull this across I think that's
that's probably true of a lot of games
that there and Last of Us is a good
example of something that would be great
like that would come across me yeah
but I think it would still the same way
as we lose something because you're not
seeing the same reason that I don't
think Assassin's Creed and Tomb Raider
worked at Roy's point which is really
because a big part of those games in the
same way the tension is a huge part of
the lost of us is the sense of discovery
and that comes with playing them so sure
you could feed me descriptive Assassin's
Creed and you could tell me about these
religious figures and these pieces of
Eden and the people that came before you
all that law but one of the strongest
almost cohesive parts of at least the
first four games in the Assassin's Creed
franchise is that you are the one who is
discovering those things the same
applies to Tomb Raider you are the one
who solved that tomb same as uncharted
whereas I feel like if you just watch
someone else do that sure but it loses
but you know it's a void so you're
you're removing something but if you had
something about like I would love an
assassin's creed that was like as
dramatically coolers like Wolf Hall have
you ever seen Wolf Hall like this
amazing TV show definitely look up Wolf
Hall it's some my favorite thing ever
it's like it's about it's about Henry
the eighth but it's about his the people
around him rather than him it's Britt
willful google it but that's like an
example of like a TV drama like a I
guess it probably adds up to about four
hours of television which is all about
political intrigue and conspiracy and
characters mentally TV shows and not
films you can't you can I so my point is
I think you can absolutely do in
Assassin's Creed movie but you have to
replace that all the stuff you're taking
away with something else like you do a
really great period drama with an
interesting sci-fi experiment you you do
source code source codes a great film
why not do historical source code that
would be an entertaining movie I would
enjoy watching source code but it's you
know yeah a historical setting so you
can't just remove you have to add you
you can't I think that's a mistake a
conscious and a make is they trying they
try and film the game yeah yeah I think
what you're but you're what you're
pointing out though is that like a lot
of these earlier games that have no
story to speak of empower the filmmaker
to do whatever the hell they want which
what that implies to me is because
generally speaking there is a movement
away from making games like that and we
seem you know games like The Last of Us
being touted as as you know kind of the
the front lines of the art form in in
many respects and and a lot of others
like it it means that filmmakers are
increasingly kind of being handed a full
menu 8-bit jamming in on this so yeah it
seems like it seems like because games
are generally not being made that thinly
that that it's gonna be it's gonna be
impossible to adapt any like current
generation games as successfully then I
guess based on what you're saying of
what empowered like Pokemon and/or
Pikachu rather and Sonic to work in in
so far as I think the adaptation
technique will change I think it's like
the mall like Marvel movies right if you
you could make an argument it would be a
very weak argument that the Marvel
movies are each adapting the previous
Marvel movie
kind of pulling across guardians of the
galaxy is set in the same universe as
Captain America they've pulled over
enough of those elements that it feels
like it shares an environment the shares
characters in universe feel there is no
reason you couldn't take a Last of Us
and tell a different story in the Last
of Us universe or that same story but in
a different way that's I mean that's
what yeah video game or even just the
slide characters right those little
characters we got a moment within the
game going tell me a story about this
one of the gears of war novels deals
with or maybe it's even the comic deals
with how they are dealing with
reproduction like it just gets into like
well a lot of humans have died in this
wall what are we doing about that and it
just takes that facet and moves it there
and dumps you in it and I think that's
really interesting like books and comic
adaptations of videogames do a great job
of fleshing stuff out a lot of the time
it's almost weird that films aren't
trying to do the same thing but yet to
circle back Austin before we end the
podcast if my answer is that I don't
think execs understand the appeal why
why do you think that that video game
adaptations have so much trouble
ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai I largely agree
with that and I think it's because it's
not even it's it's not even that they
don't understand the appeal it's that
the appeal is something that is is
intrinsically out of reach of a passive
medium of film you know like as I have
this conversation people every now and
again someone will tweet at me and say
like wouldn't journey be an interesting
movie and I'm like that sounds horrible
like to me yeah cuz journey is journey
is the whole point like a Richard
LaMarche and once told me that he was
the the the lead designer of Uncharted 1
2 & 3
he once said like the whole joy of games
is if you poke it it wobbles and Mike is
the
yeah exactly Austin if you poke it Jesus
and so yeah to me and that's all that
journey is journey is solely interaction
there is the all the storytelling is
told through the interaction there is no
there are no I mean there are a couple
of novel cutscene ish moments but
they're they're largely to masks a
loading screen like it's it's it's I
mean that's not actually that's unfair
they are telling a story but but the all
the substantive storytelling comes
through the interaction it was designed
it was designed to have almost to have
nothing else to the experience beyond
that and you know it's not trying to
imply a larger universe even though
there is peripheral storytelling you
know it is it is not meant to feel like
a launch of a franchise all that kind of
stuff and so to me yeah all the things
that would make it potentially fodder
for film don't exist but even games that
are less rigorously designed as that
have that same that same issue I mean
you know everything that you guys were
saying you know I in Tomb Raider I'm the
one that solved the puzzle that opened
the door and made the stone slide to the
side and when and like watching watching
especially this like ham-fisted version
where it's like oh I have a diary that
this and that and it's like loads of
plot contrivance --is to make something
approaching that happen it's just it's
so many degrees removed from the thing
that made it appealing that it's like I
don't even think it's possible it's just
and and and and the flip is also true I
can't stand when films are when games
rather there are dope so desperately
just trying to be movies you know that's
kind of taking us back to all the whole
kojima conversation of like dude do you
just want to make it I asked him and he
said he'd prefer to make video games
because they're harder to make
I now must run lest I miss my flight too
yes miss you that would be a bummer
everyone stay safe out there yeah I
would it would ruin the dynamic of the
show wouldn't know Mike said it is and
he's British so he sounds small okay I'm
British so he's not just British but he
made a game he says yeah he not just
that but his pedigree is I made a game
called quarantine circular he has and so
it's true yeah it's like where we're at
we're doubly at his mercy that the the
accent drawing on research for
quarantine circular means we all just
need to get in line and agree and now
it's daytime he looks all that more
authoritative you just you know like I
could Skype call you with that white
background and I'd be like so I have X
by now what do I do like my face is
somehow pale oh thank you everyone for
listening just as a reminder because I
feel like people keep forgetting this is
a monthly podcast last Friday of every
month that's when it comes out people
keep being like where's the next episode
I'm like it's monthly it hasn't
disappeared thank you guys for your
inputs on sonic Troy probably don't need
to see it the film is fine all right
we'll see you guys next month bye